to welcome everybody to the specialist
Epis the best episode of the best show
Wow
what a treat a street podcast is here
with my dog shredder
Alfredo and ela today we are sponsored
by expressvpn and Stitch fix and first
off first of all welcome everybody thank
you for joining us we have a fantastic
show playing here today for you as
always I want to first issue an apology
to ela I said that her post office story
at last episode was a 5 and it actually
resonated with a lot of people and so I
do want to issue a public apology and to
to revise my rating and I'll give it a 7
based on the overwhelming audience
reaction thank you apology accepted
well we actually had a funny anecdote
from one of our fans they wrote in he
said because I had said what's going on
with this this mail forwarding what yeah
stop anyone from just forwarding mail
anywhere right and so this guy he says
he works for USPS for those of you who
don't know we're talking about Ella had
a heck of a time at the post office
trying to Ford mail to her new address
and they ultimately said just put it in
the mail we don't need to verify your
information and I said well what's to
stop anyone from forwarding anybody's
mail even though they technically
thought that my forms were filled by
someone else and they still told me just
put it in the mailbox which is obviously
less secure safe as they can check your
ID and verify that even if it was signed
by somebody else it's still you
regardless
here this guy says I am a supervisor for
USPS I saw the segment on your recent
podcast of Aeolus problem at the post
office I thought I would share with you
the process of which a change of address
card goes through and how incredibly
insecure it is like Ethan said you can
literally change anybody's address
although it is a federal crime and if
you get caught you can make you can face
many years of imprisonment - all you
trolls out there
well it's gonna be pretty easy not to
get caught I don't know if you can just
put this papi they'll believe mailbox on
the street he says here's a link to a
news article which a guy this is the
best
he put a change of address and had UPS
headquarters address changed to his home
is that the ultimate UPS headquarters
let me repeat that forwarded to his home
address not only that let me pop this
story up
he started cashing their checks don't
you need an ID for that like he goes he
forded their address in 2017 he
requested changing a corporate mailing
address from addressing Atlanta to an
address in Chicago an apartment on
Chicago's North Side yeah
UPS is headquarters is in his apartment
in Chicago's North Side the post office
duly updated the address and he began
receiving the company's mail including
checks it went on for months
prosecutors say he deposited fifty eight
thousand dollars in checks that was
improperly forwarded to adjust what a
system failure
he receives them donut and going on for
month how can he deposit their checks
though no like that's even crazier this
guy must be thinking to himself like
this is next change like Amazon yeah you
know I heard a story I think we maybe we
talked about it where someone was just
sending invoices to Google and they
ended up getting paid like millions of
dollars just do you just send him an
invoice like hey you owe me money and
counts like yeah he got caught
eventually but he probably spent all the
money so he had a good-ass year before
he went to jail and you know when Google
comes after you go to jail for life you
look you don't get the death sentence
when Google comes after you uh so there
you have it I don't know how he was able
to cast check yes I'm still waiting to
see if my form actually went through it
didn't I guarantee it because that lady
was after you too she probably went in
there and ripped it up
no but I was surprised your because
according to the other ladies there who
seem to be on my side
yeah right they said just put it in the
mailbox
there's no difference it's the same
thing it's like do you not see a problem
with that post people yeah according to
her I'm committing a crime right now and
you guys are okay with letting me put it
in the mailbox no you're not committing
a crowd you're not impersonating
yourself according to her I am right she
thinks that my form was wrong
wrongfully filled by someone else she
she wouldn't accept it from me so
according to her there is a crime of a
new one whatever the post office day I
think what they do is they literally go
to like rehabilitation centers and they
go to like places where you check
yourself in you know and they recruit
people to work at the post office from
there they tout their health plans and
don't think that what happens it says
what it sounds like you know it's funny
also from the last episode my parents
were offended by the boomer accusation
against boomers yeah I was shocked by
this whole I was this Boomer thing
getting so out of control it's just a
gag I mean yeah boomers are are annoying
I mean but like actually that they're
actually getting offended by this boomer
my parents go just so you know Ethan you
know yes college went up for you but
guess who has to pay it the Boomers I
was like first of all not everybody's
paying for college and by the way you
wouldn't have to pay for my college and
I wouldn't have to be so dependent on
you if I could just pay my college with
$26 if what the tips I got for my
part-time work also your mom said that
they were politically they protested
Vietnam yeah but I mean that's I don't
think that's really what people complain
about I'm talking about the attitude
they have that they had much easier time
and then they're giving [ __ ] to
Millennials for being lazy when
Millennials aren't lazy they're just
shafted they don't understand that yeah
but anyway it's not that serious either
it's just
it's a stupid meme and now all of a
sudden now it's serious now there's like
generation wars there used to be race
Wars and others generation wars so the
boomers are upset and I don't think that
makes Boomer even funnier you know other
updates in my life as you guys are all
on the edge of your seat here with these
updates I'm happy to say that I'm still
a vegetarian after the Arby's meat
Mountain and I think you are V's fan now
I mean I'll be happy to say if I keep
this up that the Arby's meat Mountain
was the last time I eat meat American we
even had a barbecue over the weekend and
I held strong we got some beyond meat
sausages that were fantastic and I'm
telling you these beyond meats are just
as enjoyable as meat they really are and
I'll take more enjoyable to me because I
don't have to worry about what kind of
gross thing am i eating sure like when I
normal hotdogs I'm I don't really enjoy
because I'm also paranoid about what I'm
what I'm eating there's a texture issue
it's like chewy and that you're eating
out of it a pig's a test in I mean it's
kind of gnarly but here's the thing it
tastes delicious I'm not going to
dispute that but people keep now going I
don't know if this is some kind of meat
propaganda but every time I bring up
beyond meat they go oh did you know it's
not that healthy I'd say yeah enough in
a sausage is it's not supposed to be
healthy it's it's junk food it's a
barbecue the point is I'm not eating
meat yeah I don't understand this whole
we've heard it already from a few it's
did you but did you I'm not eating it
because I think it's healthy did you
know that it's not healthy
oh you shouldn't eat that it's like dude
you're eating a pork sausage
there's probably feces and like
Salmonella like 50% of that sausage is
feces of salmonella and that's a very
American like why is that even and I
just looked it up and it's like
nutritionists say veggie burger is
healthy despite being processed oh is
that what it is I feel like they're
being cannibalized by their own people
but they don't weigh wise
it's a veggie burger it's just not meat
I'm not I'm not eating a it to be
healthy it's not meat and it's still a
hamburger that's the point
nobody's saying oh did you know how
hamburgers not healthy yeah we know that
it's it's a it's a you know it's a treat
okay now I'm a militant vegetarian but
I'm happy to say that the feeding window
has persisted the vegetarian has
persisted feeding window plus
vegetarianism equals true euphoria true
enlightenment here's what they they said
that most of the nutritionist classified
the veggie burger as a sometimes food
meaning it can be healthy to eat on
occasion as a substitute to real food
I'll shut up to them I say that it's
like did you really need a research on
that that just seems like common sense
how about just shut up and let me eat my
veggie burger what do you do you
classify a real burger Oh sometime food
probably there you go sometimes
everything I eats is sometime food if
you mix up the sometime foods enough
then your then your you know I'm saying
you eat a burger on this day a pizza on
this day they this sometimes that's
sometimes that sometimes I'm healthy you
just rotate you know but I think I'm
losing weight I think I'm losing weight
I think I'm losing weight I think my
belts a little less a little less
everything becomes a song I go I am the
thing is that I have a lot of fat not
just my stomach now but with my arms my
thighs my wheel I got fat all over the
place go today
anyway I think I'm losing weight so
that's exciting I like the feeling
window I like the vegetarianism and I
love the vegetarianism wait hold on Gila
you got to admit happy that were
vegetarian for days strong you got to
admit something about the feeding window
that you were hating again go ahead go
ahead about the feeding window I think
that it's wonderful really because I see
how are you responding to it I feel like
I'm talking about a baby now you're
responding really well to the feeding
window mm-hm
and it's eliminating the late-night
snacks mm-hmm which is perfect for you
it keeps you on a schedule which is
perfect for you it keeps me on a
schedule because I know when you're
eating and I know that you're not gonna
come at me at midnight with like pizza
requests yeah so there's less stress for
me too I'm pretty much just eliminating
a meal for my day yeah just forces me
not to eat that third meal it's
fantastic
had a cup of tootsie rolls you know no
saying and back to here we got a bunch
of candy left over and it's a beautiful
thing you want to look at h3 memes of
the week it's Tuesday yeah but also
you're not abusing the window no I would
never abuse the window me how dare you
all right so here we as you know we'd
like to go over on reddit.com our slash
hthe productions we like to go over you
guys put all the effort into these
beautiful lovely memes and every Tuesday
we go over the freshest spiciest H
straight reproduction memes of the week
dan by the way just remember I want to
have people call in and leave messages
for us voice messages yeah okay how do
we do that I used to do it last year you
have the numbers to do is it is it open
I can it's not right now but I can
reactivate it okay well we'll figure
that out turn the break 808 ha Meem is
it really 808 hot
and that's such a good non-drive like a
million different combos and that was so
we got to open that up 808 hot meme you
guys click all in like message question
I concern we will address it on the show
when fashion a confession right
shoenice made another weird video about
us did you got it I don't know what he's
problem is cuz it's like when I start
warming up to him and I want to have
don't tell me this I just made contact
with him let me show you the video you
can tell me what you think
come on I don't know what's his problem
he's the one who's mad at me and then
he's gonna stalk me true well that's
that's better for me frankly but every
time this happens I make connection with
him I start warming up I think could be
a great podcast guess I do I just don't
know what shoenice is gonna show up and
I'll tell you what I mean like there's a
shoenice where he's like shout out to
you know Ethan in Gila I didn't mean it
I want to be on your show and then maybe
he probably erased it guys guys I'm not
entirely I mean he has so many channels
though let's see I mean he sent me an
email that said I am the most nonviolent
person in the world I run from
confrontations and he's been going
through long you've got
you got to see this video okay I like
that message the most nonviolent person
in the world more than I mean that's
what he says okay how do we how do we
how do we quantify that that's almost
like vicious yeah that's suspicious
I do you know something else that
concerns me somebody said careful Ethan
this is literally the same thing that
happened in Joker when they invited
Harvey what was his name Harvey late
night and and he liked that comment he's
favored that comment okay but also is it
I think you're a stick god damn it you
nice buddy always erase [ __ ] man
see he had emailed me because I we were
busy last week and I had moved out to
him yet and yeah I think he got sad
about it and got me a very sad email
saying I'm out much love to you guys but
you know I understand you don't want me
around or whatever and I emailed him
back I said she nice no don't don't be
like that
you should have reached to reach out to
him sooner though because we could ask
everything what I'm trying to say is
everything's back on track and I'm
talking to him and so maybe that's what
you now but now you're well he erased
the video in the video he goes uh he
goes even in ela he's like I mean I'm
telling you he's like off sure it's a
new video it yes it just came out like
yesterday and he erased it if you go to
his channel his newest videos from six
days ago so he goes on a racing spree he
goes Ethan and ela stop [ __ ] talking
about me you always clickbait me and it
always gets you more views well it's
[ __ ] and it's time to stop talking
about me get might get your name out of
my mouth before I and then he starts but
uh he starts threatening me he goes
Ethan you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and if I
see you I'm gonna do something you know
vine he said and he goes I'm just
kidding I scared you didn't I Ethan you
[ __ ] it's like I mean I'm saying almost
verbatim what he said just so unhinged I
know I don't like see I don't like that
side of Shu knives well why don't we we
don't have to have a man we could we
could do like a Skype call yeah why
don't we do that just do like a remote
we got it because not the same idea you
got a date I've got an idea if we bring
shoenice in what if we put him in a
straitjacket let's put him in a
straitjacket with a call okay yeah do
you like the straitjacket idea well you
know we'll take it off well just he will
be like look before you into the room
we'll have our security guard before you
into the room I'm gonna frisk you and
then I'm gonna put this straitjacket on
you and then you can come me Ethan and
ela
too much let's start with a call what
about like a Hannibal mask over his face
in addition to this JJ too far
no that's reasonable I just want to feel
safe I'm sure he'll understand after
that last video new video yeah I don't
know if you're AC he's got like a
thousand chance okay so maybe this hard
have been on shoenice ASMR let's go I
mean how do I find all the showers she
nice official channel does he have a
Boomer Channel is he a Boomer you know I
don't think he's a Boomer he's Gen X I
think um let's see I mean let me sort by
no he has like 20 channels so it's hard
okay let me sort by upload date the
thing is I know he does I think he does
constantly erase videos so but what is
this again well basically I've been on
YouTube nine years next month
same with h3h3 maybe 10 years I've seen
Ethan's videos 6 7 8 years ago I've
always known Ethan anniela good people
they're a family now I'm sober I guess
in their last podcast they mentioned
having me on there again I'm one of the
greatest YouTube stories ever straight
up to this 10,000 animal again Paul gets
me deleted I'm back up to 100k again I'm
not disagreeing with you nice chance on
YouTube that's why I want to have it on
the show I don't even I know your
producer you're all good people sure I
get drunk and I say stuff I say to
everybody I'm a raw comic but you guys
knows I'm down inside I got a good heart
and a good song and so from this
directly after the other
out of your think who's wearing the same
hat we can even have the interview maybe
outside you guys come to Denver now how
you can be got a baby either you want to
show your kid right now that what does
that sound legit it seemed very nice
that's not the one that's not the one
all right maybe you had a nightmare no
you guys I'm gonna find this hold on now
you really pissing me off
shoenice addresses false rape
allegations oh wow
do I even want to go there probably she
knows flips out on Ethan eel again here
it's the same day or no that's the other
video yeah look November 11 it's a
faster day
okay there you have it no this is re
uploaded from this guy shoenice deleted
videos X I think is either him or
someone who so here okay just just enjoy
this yesterday right of that room is a
veteran Ethan ela the producer who
whatever your name is reunited stop
mentioning my name per views every time
you mention my name
you get views and you know it stop it
come to Denver and we'll chat put me on
skype and we'll chat but it's open shut
the [ __ ] up and don't mention my [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's him drunk and then the
other ones him sober I guess well not
that bad names he's sober but it's just
but who is this I don't know who this
sword
that was uploaded I think that's gotta
be the most recent yeah that was
yesterday and then the one I'd already
made peace with him so so yes so this
one the first one we watched of him
being on is that's why I deleted it was
from the seventh and this one being
psycho was from the ninth from the ninth
yes no no Saturday yeah I think it's on
Veterans Day he said happy Veterans Day
not if you sit on the 9th or not oh it's
a but this one this ok so what do you
make of it I believe I emailed him
apologizing for not getting back to him
sooner on Saturday so maybe he posted
that video then emailed me and my
shoenice I'm trying to tell you it on
the video if if we're not getting back
to you it's Dan's fault it's not me it's
Dan's fault dancey dance the [ __ ] I
explained you Dan explained everything
in the email I explained it on the
podcast then is a busy guy we got a lot
of work for then
I'm clipping that Dan is a busy guy [ __ ]
you that's such a good sound bite well
okay let's get on a Skype call with him
let's plan that out look we will pre
record it get a little into the mind of
shoenice he's got a lot of voices
rolling around he's Marge she's joked or
no we're about to look at the memes
though have something to ask you about
oh you have something won't put on the
veil on the window oh I guess not
okay you want to send it on discord ah
that window just disappeared to know her
so anyway let's get back to the memes we
got sidetracked with Tosh shoenice
but I mean he says he can't fly by the
way he says he's gonna be in LA sometime
in the fall I believe you said isn't it
the fall now yes it is so then why don't
you find out but I think it's a guy over
station first it was like the first date
right right and then and then we'll take
it from there
beautiful foreplay I get it set up next
Tuesday let's go dude he could he could
literally I'm just saying if he's here
he could lunch he the lunch across the
table and chew and strangle my head off
and like before you could even react
he's got crazy energy dude I don't think
that he's a violent guy well apparently
he's been accused of rape that's
according to some random YouTube video
do we investigate that right now no no
Dan says oh good call good call right
cue nice I don't know I doubt that it's
just some random youtube video sorry but
if you have B if it was Dan it's all Dan
so here's the memes for the week guys
you're in the wrong Street cuz ela is
pointing a gun at Trish and she's
running that's violent Trish just starts
hitting on Heath enos's that's true oh
is that the wire thing that's from the
wire could be wrong when you
successfully hit candy in the shop
car and your mom bought it anyway that's
the NRA you're so happy with that lolly
I love that one so much it's no happy
that could be a good shirt image for an
Dan trying to end the show Ethan talking
powerful I like that the boys well I
guess I should describe these for the
for the listeners know I've been putting
them in the O show description of very
nice I heard my version been getting
some good feedback for that nice if you
if you're an audio listener and you
haven't noticed that yet all of the
links to everything we watch and look at
are in the description how wonderful how
what a sweet thoughtful gesture Dan it's
Greta the little girl Greta staring at
Trump so that's what that is
the boys will they try to educate
themselves on the female hymen it's all
of us you know being very confused and
eva is not interested in this
conversation ti here just checking ins
it's a view from his daughters vagina
looking out into q nice is the Joker
that's that's the Batman we deserve
that's a good Joker man that's a
terrifying Joker that's too realistic
and would that Batman stop that Joker do
you think and this universe they're
supposed to struggle right it doesn't
mean he's it's his equal it's his man
right Joker is his aunt dented this is a
Batman I'm team Batman when your boss is
saying something controversial and
digging himself into a hole and your
help will stop him so you just have to
watch him crash and burn that didn't
happen
what is he referring to no no no no I
don't know what he's referring to this I
like a lot you can with the new belt
Delphine video you and my girl business
I want to watch this source video know
what is only the Japanese a spring show
can you pull up that uh
I want to watch that don't you try and
find it yeah I try to find it it's like
acid you guys this is us eating sour
this FDA approved an I'm going in for
round two yeah a she podcast worried
about eating segments on the podcast me
running to the sound of Ethan's lip
smacking pornhub is this real porn hub
offers TI's daughter one no no lose
virginity I want to be surprised as a
joke apparently something they would do
and they then they flip your [ __ ]
it's Charlie from always funny the
conspiracy mean and Zack taking my mom
asking where all the Vaseline went me
explaining it help with my itchy butt
hole I mean that's what Vaseline is for
that's one of the applications of a
sling am I wrong slang for if not to put
in your butt irritated skin yes that's
what I'm talking just happens to be in
your butt
I'm babies mmm-hmm sensitive skin when
mom says you can't adopt a blue go well
ela said well this I love the shrunken
Joker it's Ethan and SAS both with the
need Mountain I don't know why I love
this Zack is my meat Mountain accomplice
army of darkness
it's me with a Papa bless and he loved
my leg
Donnie dolls deep cuts so flow bro
sexual 2x oh that's a good a strong an
army of dankness okay well break time oh
well we've managed to discuss nothing
why really yeah well we went on a whole
shoenice tangent their generation um dan
i do want to ask you something would you
help me bury a body
what dan let's let's talk about after
the break but i wanna i really want to
know if it would help to bury a body I
mean I want to know how
as a producer I want to know where your
limit no let's let's go to a quick break
and we'll be right back when find out
damn would help me bury buddy or not
maybe it's that I think Zach would we'll
find out we got a lot to talk about the
mandalorian we all watched sanic is back
and looking juicy Epstein has an
egg-shaped penis we'll get into that
maggot challenge ooh this one's fun and
of course Logan Palmer's case I fight I
want to talk about that and so so so so
so much more more violence at Popeye's
my goodness
I heard that Trump declared a national
emergency this morning over Popeyes in
displaying he is deploying national
guards who all popped by locations
around the country so the price of
chicken is has a toll on all of us so we
will be right back after this break
what you would to my online services
does the government have a right to now
pink dye searches what about penis
enlargement surgery what about where to
pirate the game cupcake bake-off
they don't overwrite the CIA let my
privates are guys none of the above if
you have expressvpn without expressvpn
protection though hackers and
governments and had companies and ice
peace ISPs all have full access to your
data I don't want them using my web
history or video searches against me
that's why I use expressvpn
every time I go on at first VPN
encryption reroute your web traffic to
any number of countries keeping you safe
and secure simply download the
expressvpn app click an app and boom
you're protected without Swiss VPN you
can make it seem like your browsing from
a different country so you can watch any
Netflix and library in the world if you
want how cool is that
lightning sound effect expressly PN it's
the fastest VPN I've tried it costs less
than seven dollars per month and it
comes with a 30-day money-back guarantee
- it's time to stop governments and
Internet companies from keeping tabs on
your data
take back your online privacy like I did
today with a call to action
protect your online activity today and
find out how you can get three months
for free and expressvpn com+ h3 that's e
ex BR e SS VPN dong cobb / h 3 for 3
bucks for room with a one-year package
big expressvpn comm / a trade alert
you
[Music]
describe your look in one word casual
sophisticated playful ela put your phone
away I'm talking to Jesus however you
dress stitch fix as the expert person a
stylist that can help you look your best
personal style is like a fingerprint ela
everyone has their own whatever style
they're experts stylish yet stitch fix
are ready to help you express yourself
not all clothing or a fit for everyone
with stitch fix your personal stylist
will send you clothing that make you
look your very best less one size fits
all more this fits your style stitch fix
is an online personal styling service
that delivers your favorite clothing
brands right to your door is my
impression is it awful to get started
don't use stitch fix comm / h3 answer
some questions about your preferred
style and your personal shopper will
ship you a box of clothes shoes and
accessories with stitch fix everyone can
look their best
they have solutions for men women kids
all over the United States and now but
the UK there's no could be been required
and you only pay for what you keep
shipping exchanges a return plus the $20
styling fee is automatically applied
towards anything you keep in your butts
the next you'll never have to think
about looking good again with stitch fix
get started today at stitch fix calm /h
Lee and you get a extra 25% ah when you
keep everything in your books that
stitch fix that come / each thing once
again that stitch fix calms logic Sri
darling
so as I was saying Dan as my producer if
I called you and said Dan I need your
help with something
you of course would oblige me as the
good crepe producer you are I said you
come over my house and there's some dead
guy and in a room or something and I say
love well let's let's get rid of this
uh-huh
what do you do I'd probably have some
questions like what would you ask me it
was totally justified it was everything
was justified about it so like in
self-defense it was self-defense
someone broke into the house let's just
say someone broke into the house and I
blast him with the shotty and he died on
my floor
I mean if it was really justified when
you just reported because we have work
to do
I mean burying a body that's that is
work and that's that's hard to work than
we do for a living
maybe maybe like I shot him in the back
so it's like wow so it just looks a
little fishy it's a little fishy but I
don't know and in your house yeah in my
house stand your ground laws or whatever
I don't know Callie I think I think yeah
I think if you shoot him in the back
it's you can get [ __ ] you might get
[ __ ] so I'm like dude look this guy
came in my house I'm sure yeah
I mean any of these circumstances yeah
let's go are you serious
that was bringing your house I mean you
know what he was trying to get you know
a lot like what do we do
well I go down I need what do we do oh
what's the game plan
we got a tarp or anything uh yeah I'll
get a tarp
I got a tarp and we'll go out halfway to
Vegas hmm you know out in the middle of
the boonies Death Valley or something
I'll be fine
Death Valley Oh dig a hole it's it's
gonna be okay and then what do we do
about like the blood on the floor and in
the car and stuff like that um well good
Zach take care of that bleach yeah you
can be our uh I didn't expect I didn't
expect you to say yes
well I mean you said is justified it was
yeah fully justified what's going on
either would you help me with that
yes yeah I got you thank you thank you
guys I feel very loved right now now by
the way during this whole process I'll
be taking a lot of photos secretly three
to six months later then are you chewing
in the mic come on how much [ __ ] do uh
you're gonna give me [ __ ] for that Ethan
really no I'm the one that's eat while
you're talking honestly no I got Ethan
so what you're gonna be worried you're
gonna you can talk pictures free well
guess what I'm taking pictures at the
same time and I'll say with your idea in
three months I'll put I'll [ __ ]
betray you did happen in your house I
don't own a gun you do okay but you're
an accomplice so you're already yeah
even if you rat me out no more monsters
though you got a kid so life is
everything I don't really care right now
that now this theoretical is just out of
control because you're not taking it
seriously anymore what I'm taking it
very seriously mmm-hmm
you're an accomplice at this point if
you bring me down even if it's justified
and you turned me in you are still gonna
go to prison yeah but again you have a
lot more to lose I feel like you are so
what has that what does that affect you
so you know it affects me what are you
gonna blackmail me what do you mean by
that I mean I didn't use that word okay
let's move on deniz now change the set
this is not whatever I wanted this to go
wait so how would you dispose of the
body he would well according to Dan who
you got it all wrong got it all oh you
did yeah you got it from what I've seen
my movies mmm-hmm you got a new start
limb from limb so you pull the teeth out
of the head yeah so you cut the leg off
you got the other leg off and you cut
the two arms off and then you spread
them around so that way it's harder to
find the body
well I don't see how that help well if
they found an arm they'd still be able
to identify them by their DNA this is
what I've seen in the movies all the
movie I don't get it yeah I don't get
that strategy that just seems like Oh
[ __ ] and a big mess I like I think
bearing it in the middle of the desert
is a good call he's right if you just go
half way to Vegas
drive five miles into the desert
dig a hole call it a day yeah I mean
that seems pretty clean one and done I
don't I don't think I say you call the
police call the police okay I know I
know who not to call
[Laughter]
I also before we review the mandalorian
I also want to say that I'm a bit a boy
now because at the new house we can't
use baby wipes after after all this time
we can't use baby wipes and there's a
bidet in the toilet and I never thought
I would use this kind of a day but I'm
like well hell I'm just gonna sit on a
try it's unlike anything else I've used
where you face the wall and you have
your hands on the handles like your
starship pilot sick you you're like
getting so with the temperature it's
like a little hot local note I mean and
you're getting the pressure up and
there's a jet that shoots right at your
[ __ ] high-pressured so basically
feels amazing it's Finn the pressure is
super high
you always had concerns about what do
you do then when you're wet because you
can't use toilet paper here's what I
misunderstood people acting like you
just [ __ ] and get over the bidet but no
you cannot do that that's insane what
you need to do is you wipe all the you
know yeah let's say Ground Zero that's
what I like to refer to the first like
five wipes and and at that point I would
go in for a baby wipe but instead of
going for a baby wipe for the you know
how do you want to do that though you
know you're it's the it's the rubble
you're going in with the bulldozer and
cleaning up the
you know you don't want to breathe the
fumes cuz you'll get a cancer later down
the road but but instead of using a baby
wipe you sit on the bidet and at that
point you're already clean but you're
just taking out the trash but what do
you do afterwards you just wet so at
that you know at that point there's
actually a towel rack next to it so
you're not wiping your ass that's what I
understand you're just trying your
thighs so but I haven't been using a
towel I just been I go high-pressure and
then I turn it off and I just kind of
jiggle jiggle the water off as best I
can I put on my pants it's not that bad
but what I would do if I put a towel
there and I'm going to is just dry your
thighs and your prayer and that's it I'm
telling you my [ __ ] has been like
cleaner than it's ever been
it feels great you ever had high stream
water plane blown out your [ __ ] did
well nice and warm it's super high
pressure and you can you can like go
higher pressure than you're comfortable
with and sometimes it squirts in your
ass the water and I'm like I didn't like
that well but that's an option I
recommend using a brown tall know it but
I'm telling you there won't be any [ __ ]
on it a brown towel that's hideous
that's awful where's everything I've got
some questions about the mechanics of
this because the way you describe that
now this is a is this thing built into
the toilet no separate unit you'd like
to stand like you you walk over to it
yeah and you're like so in the same room
so any little water walk no no I'm wiped
my ass it's not that serious okay like I
like I just like right next to each
other you [ __ ] you can wipe and you say
you do like you do like three wipes to
get the chunks out you flush that so you
move on to the bidet you sit on the day
it's just it's like one step away you
don't even have to waddle okay it's in
the bathroom you sit on it you face the
wall and there's a knob so it's like
it's no we didn't think that anything
would like it
so we already bought the total toilets
we bought the todos
maybe I'll but those are cool cuz they
try your ass and I think I like the
totem
it opens for you so you don't touch
though this is the one that Tom and
Christine yeah yeah yeah okay and you
don't have to touch the toilet seat ever
cuz it opens when you enter the room Wow
do you use a bar of soap on the bidet
like the clean what yeah that's what
you're supposed to do you're supposed to
like so you're supposed to do what do
you know
nobody soaps their [ __ ] that's right
less you're in the shower
that's insane you can have too much
conversation I'm not touching my [ __ ]
effort I mean I think we shouldn't
really know what everyone is doing it's
way too late for that dealer yeah are
you bringing that up no no that doesn't
make any sense
get some extra clean where do you know
I've actually trips open to prove you're
not suppose of what soap your [ __ ]
when you're on the day that's crazy why
well first of all why is it necessary at
second while you're putting your hand in
your [ __ ] that's defeats the whole
purpose of the cleanliness but it's soap
Zach you're not serious no I've tried it
like I'm dead serious
so tell me about the process of soaking
your [ __ ] after your check well I
like you I do the wipe and just to get
the extra clean when you go on the bidet
you know you get the water right and
then you know you wet the soap and you
go like a bar oh so you hope you have a
you have a place for soap I don't have a
bidet in my house but like sometimes in
hotels there'd be a bidet and I've used
that so you just leave there's no place
for soap next to the bidet you just
leave it in the bidet in the bidet what
do you mean on the bowl with the [ __ ]
water inside the [ __ ] water goes
down it passes over the Sun no way let's
discuss you leave a but you leave a
Bardot's know what you know but you know
that's not the let Zach let me ask you
something is the person who told you you
flip the [ __ ] the wrong this is
first-hand experience okay but do you
understand that here you there's no way
that the intention is to leave a bar
soap in the bowl of the bidet I you
don't touch you don't you have to reach
in and grab this will be touching the
bidet bowl which is where [ __ ] water
goes flows but why does someone else use
is it actually you're at a hotel even
more horoscope you're at a hotel with
other people and other people stayed
there that's or if none of this adds up
I've stayed in a lot of hotels I've
never seen one of these are you sure
Vegas I've seen a bagina
I've seen it with DES in a hotel but I
did not I think you just grabbed the
soap it doesn't mean that they set it up
like that you don't have right the way
bar soap worth you grab like the bottom
end of the soap and then you wipe it's
almost like you're wiping with the sober
row yet soap has been in other people's
ass no it's a brand new so and then so
would you throw it out you leave it in
the bowl and our is anyone else using
the soap and hotel room only me no [ __ ]
on the soap hold on how do you know that
no one else is sitting on that bidet if
you're you're not there by yourself
right like you're not in the hotel room
by yourself
are you by yourself no okay I would make
sure okay yeah and so you leave it in
the bowl does anyone else use the bidet
no why would no one else uses the daemon
the only one that likes it okay and now
this is something you do or they don't
tell me that there's a girlfriend there
with you no no no yeah cuz she would
break up with you as was years ago but
you so you you started the conversation
by saying this is what people do and I
want you to revise that this is what
I've been told by who told you that I I
saw someone told me that I hope you soap
your butt on the bidet how does water
clean it well and high-pressured it's
like a power clean but you still need
some type of bro you don't soap your
[ __ ] after you wife ever you you
start with lead your [ __ ] to be so
we're gonna eat your the first time they
like walk your own yeah this is part of
the tour they show you who's the soap
they leave the Soleil of the soap inside
yes let the ship water flush yeah you
start with the water okay so your butt
is moist and then you you use the soap
and then you clean it out there's no
need for you to soap your [ __ ] but
don't you want it extra clean for what I
don't know don't you want the brown to
go bye-bye
that's it's a high-pressure power wash
that's how it works I don't want to
touch my [ __ ] that defeats the
purpose you understand that the minute
you touch your [ __ ] the old the whole
process is null and void no youyou
you're objectively wrong Zack I need you
to know this be that as it may I still
have tried it okay and so did you what
need to wash your hands afterwards oh of
course yeah yeah so you wash your
butthole you're white you when you wipe
it away with the bidet yeah then you go
and wash your hands
correct are you concerned at all that
you were just touching your shitty
[ __ ] with your hand no because my
butthole is clean now well you but
you've cut but before you use the soap
it was presumably dirty no because I you
got a wipe so you see no brown why do
you know what happens the next time you
use it do you remember which side you
can touch of the soap on which side you
can touch you gotta make a guess I guess
so you actually put the bar soap like
now and you actually touch your butthole
with the bar so yeah correct and then
you put it in the bowl that doesn't
sound sanitary the water touches your
[ __ ] and it gets flushed what happens
if there's a little bit of poop on the
soap or like an [ __ ] hair I'm gonna
ask you you make sure it's cleaning what
about an ASP you do and wash the soap
yeah you would wash this you see when
you're washing soap you know you [ __ ]
up when soap is so dirty it needs to be
washed do you understand that that
doesn't that's wrong soap is mint you
can't wash soap set okay do you ever get
it do you ever see [ __ ] people on the
soap no and if there was would you just
remove it with your hand
no I throw the soap out you would one
[ __ ] pube that's enough but you had
[ __ ] on it
there was no brown on the soap but it
was in your butthole how deep in the
butthole do you go when you put the soap
not super do not super deep so you go in
a little bit no I don't want like soap
going directly on my butt how many times
have you done this once or twice once or
twice okay so you're not exactly the
authority so yes I was just I was just
giving you an experience okay thank you
pass this story should have started with
like you know what I what I did once and
did you how does it feel getting the
water shut at your [ __ ] it's pretty
nice right yeah I mean it's a little
uncomfortable at first but I loved it
it's kind of like it's very gratifying
do you find it gets ticklish yeah yeah
it's it's like a it's like a water God
tongue and tongue in your bottle a water
goddess if I if you were I've been
trying to get you to try it are you
putting it off like yesterday I pooped
on your because you used it and they
feel like nice clothes okay if I gets
yours well yeah that's fine I love it
you're missing out though I'm impressed
by how high-pressure it is you seen
those videos of those pressure washers
where it's like you see the dirty bricks
and then they bring up the pressure wash
is brand new that's what I imagine is
going on there so there you go my bidet
boy and I haven't used baby wipes in a
minute we moved baby wipes you're
vegetarian Wow I'm kind of the perfect
perfect citizen transcended what else
can I do
oh and I can I use paper straws only cuz
I'm forced to and I hate them however
your bowel movements been since the
vegetarian diet um it's too early to
tell you know it's only been four days
okay but so far well you know I had a
little diarrhea from some Mexican food
yeah I think we had some bad food or
maybe it's just the spicy salsa always
gives me the round you know
Mexican food is always such a gimbal
it's just the spicy food I think it
really maybe really gets things flowing
well be that as it may we have a new
show reviews there is this Dora's show
no the last one was worse for sure but
we did go on this the last one was worse
let's talk about the Mandalorian the
Mandalorian is the new Disney Plus show
it apparently came out this morning at
3:00 a.m. but I downloaded Disney Plus
last night at 10 o'clock in preparation
to watch it in the morning and I got in
no problem and I watched the show last
night at 10:00 was amazing that first of
all I had no interest in getting Disney
Plus at all how Zek screw these greedy
Sons of Guns Disney there they are so
money hungry these guys they are all
Mickey Mouse on the streets and all Mick
Scrooge in the sheets thank you
so I was not ready to to shell out more
money for another monthly service but
I'll tell you I was pleasantly surprised
it's only six dollars a month though
okay that's fine I log in there there's
actually good a lot of good stuff there
including the entire National Geographic
catalogue which is really cool I know
and honestly they've got all all their
movies and [ __ ] I don't really care
about that stuff
but I put on the first episode of the
mandalorian and I'm gonna tell you guys
the honest truth I'm a lukewarm Star
Wars fan all the new Star Wars I really
didn't like that much they're just
they're they're kind of campy and stupid
and lame the original Star Wars I like
very much this is thought this is the
most Star Wars thing I've seen since the
original films everything about it is
Star Wars the universe the vibe the
feeling the character the production
value was insanely high the practical
effects like there's I'm not going to do
any spoilers here but it's high it's
like high cutting-edge movie
level like the the prosthetics and the
practical effects like of that green
alien at the beginning I was like this
looks insane I was so impressed and I
got to tell you guys the honest truth
there I get I give it a 10 out of 10 the
first step I loved everything about it
it was fun
it was Star Wars as how the movie looked
amazing it didn't it felt it's not a
movie
so the show if I mean it was just it was
so incredible was so beautiful the
pacing was great the characters was
great there's like a robot in there
which is the first robot I've actually
liked since the original you know all
these new sequels there oh they're just
trying so hard to force all these Star
Wars strobes like here's a here's Jar
Jar Binks he's like the new wookie and
here's three what was the name of the
little droid in the new ones bbbb a beat
here's bb-8 he's a cute kawaii robot
it's like they try so hard to hit all
these tropes from the original but they
just look it ends up so forced in my
opinion here they've got a robot that
feels Star Wars and original and he's
funny and awesome and it's and I was
like dude I love this robot so sick the
character I mean everything about this
they just they they nailed everything
and it takes a minute to get into it for
someone like me I feel like I wasn't
sure you looked all asleep I did fall
asleep but then we watched again here in
the morning you were tired you were you
already I'm a mom yeah I know but like
but I did love that part with the robot
yeah I'm sold
I mean so I thought it was fantastic and
I can't wait to to see where the series
goes I love the production it looks
amazing
but it was very rewarding to like a lot
of the first episodes are just kind of
like they just lackluster they just
don't take you there but this episode
not only delivered on everything else it
took me there it delivered and it got me
excited and pumped for this series it
just gets better and better as a episode
I loved it I'm in I'm a Mandalorian I'm
a bounty hunter gotta go put on my mask
and I'm never gonna take it off and I'm
gonna go hunt Bradbury's your guys's
thoughts back here yeah yeah I really
liked it too
I wouldn't like I guess my only
reservation which it didn't ruin it for
me at all but yeah I mean it like you
said they're clearly trying to hit the
vibes of the original trilogy much more
than the prequels or or whatever the
sequel trilogy I guess you'd call it the
new ones at times I kind of felt like it
was trying a little too hard cuz like
there's so many references to the
original movies just in I mean what was
it a half hour and like they were coming
so fast that at times it was just like
oh there's another you know it felt well
well just like the the aliens in the
towns or whatever I mean I you know
there was like the dude with the
elephant nose yeah and they're using
like the exact same sound effects from a
new hope and when he shows up at the
door it's like the little job a palace
like little eyeball thing comes out it
didn't bother me those are a small thing
I'm a little fanservice I'm I guess
that's what it is it was a little heavy
on the fanservice it didn't ruin it for
me at all and I agree like I loved it I
thought it was an and just as far as
like a pilot for a television show one
of the best pilots I've seen a long time
like in in terms of what a pilot
supposed to do sucking you in you know
getting you hooked on and interested to
see where it goes next blah blah blah so
yeah I mean I wouldn't give it like a 9
out of 10 a 9 out of 10 you and Dan not
get a couple points just for the Phantom
dude over indulgence of the fan sir 9
out of 10 is a is a strong yes strong
grade yeah and I I'm I'm pretty much the
same as you I loved Star Wars growing up
the prequels I kind of liked when I was
a kid but you know it wasn't super hot
on them and then just I really have not
loved these new movies at all the first
one I liked the last one was just
[ __ ] it was just dog [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
yeah the tip the blue tip milk the lot
throwing the lightsaber
I didn't wanna get into it because it
gets me so upset just awful
yeah yeah and but you know so I so I
went in with fairly low expectations but
I did too but I had heard uh I've got a
buddy who actually worked on it and he
wasn't you know he was very tight-lipped
he's under NDA and couldn't really say
anything but he had told me he was like
this show is gonna be good
trust me and he was right he was right
it was [ __ ] good I thought it was so
it's like it's about on par with the
last season of Game of Thrones what's
the budget per episode Dan I think it
was like 12.5 million
I'm impressed that they're able to was
on westward in that budget to what's
world was up there but not quite that
high but getting the last season game
thrones and this stupid show that I mean
I guess it's not stupid a lot of people
watching but this show the crown I don't
know if you guys whatever no has an
absolutely insane budget Netflix just
diarrhea's money I mean I I know people
liked it but how is the crown on the
same budget levels Game of Thrones and
Star Wars
what they spend money on did they buy
real crowds and I remember we talked
about this last time this came up and
random leave the show er back in the day
huh what's also like because I think
they were paying George Clooney like
three million dollars in episode or
something insane to be honest oh so
that's up there with the highest - but
yeah I mean the thing is is that I think
for this is probably the most expensive
first season of a show ever because
usually a show has to thank ya hit
before they're willing to put this much
money into it but I think they were so
confident that it was going to be good
that they just don't I think what's more
it is - and that range it's up there
it's a hundred million for the first
season Wow was 25 million Oh
then the per episode it's like between a
tenth and I wonder if they got the
return on on West Road if it got them
the results they're looking I thought
that shows Finn I love it I love it yeah
well anyway we are digressing the
Mandalorian is great Disney did it they
got me interested and
Plus which I never in a million years
thought would ever be a case this is
your low-grade cosplay you know and I am
looking for very cool to smelt some
metal to put on my shoulder and upgrade
my status as a candy and share your
thoughts if you would I thought it was
phenomenal how to give it a 10 out of 10
are you very good and you know Ian's got
to do it to you now Ian's a hater as
usual so let's hear what the hater has
to stay out of the bunch I don't mean to
be a hater all the time I don't want to
be it's fine
we need we need the devil's advocate as
they as N likes to point out F tear easy
[Music]
why don't you guys just talk to the
robot what's the point so you got you
give it an a I didn't I just talked to
the AI you go ahead though tell me what
you actually thought it just felt a
little kind of shallow to me a little
bit it felt kind of like like traveling
through a ride at Disneyland and you're
seeing the cool stuff but and I love
going on those rides and things like
that that's how it feels but I don't
really feel connected to anybody on this
show and maybe that's something to do
with the helmet because I'm not seeing
an actor expressing emotion and and all
that but it felt kind of like cartoony
almost in a way that isn't really my
type of stuff but I see why people like
it and it looks really good I feel like
Ian and then I I can't also see the
excitement I mean it's a little corny I
acknowledge that but it's good I mean so
is the original Star Wars go back and
watch that you know I mean I mean I he
does have a point in that in this pilot
the main character does not get an
enormous amount of characterization I
mean there's one I guess we should be if
you if you really don't want spoilers
you should probably I mean we're not
gonna explicitly know don't say any spot
we're good already you don't have to
spoil you know okay so there's that
there's a little
bit of a flashback sequence that happens
that hints that were gonna get some more
story from him but it's true he's he's
pretty he's pretty much a blank slate
even at the end and that flashback thing
felt so lazy I feel like I've seen that
like the flashback was kind of it's very
trophy
it's very trophy but but so was the
original Star Wars and that's kind of
the thing I don't necessarily dock it
for that because this felt like it was
trying to be a space Western and the in
the same way that the original was
trying to be a space like a Buck Rogers
you know 1930 space adventure thing and
so on that level I mean yeah it felt
like a it felt like a cool Western to me
but we'll have to see where the rest
it's the first episode you know the
first episode we'll see where how the
rest of it goes I first think they'd
never fallen with the helmet I like
seeing that I like the whole thing that
they've got going on those Mandalorians
I identify with that I feel that it's
it's I like the mystery there's so much
to learn about him in the Mandalorians I
think they're cool bounty hunters and
probably beautiful souls and I would
like to join their race of Mandalorian
bounty hunters totally with that being
said I think that completes our review
of the Mandalorian so check it out yeah
I think it was great and you feel free
to pirate it too it's not a big deal you
don't have to get Disney Plus okay did
you like the look of Disney Plus the
layout and yeah it seemed fine I mean I
didn't explore it that much I just
clicked mendel yeah their video player
like crashed one of our computers when
we were trying to really I heard a lot
of people were having trouble really
okay I was when I saw just a fluke but
we even rebooted the computer we were
trying to watch it on the TV out here in
the control room and every time we would
open their video player the computer
would go nuts and start turning off
monitors yeah when I went on Twitter
earlier it was like Disney Plus failed
yeah that's what I saw I don't know if
it's just that they're they have a lot
of traffic or what I mean like I said I
didn't expect to be able to watch it
yesterday at 10:00 p.m. it was fantastic
I think
I think it was yeah City I think la for
whatever reason they launched it early
here well anyway yeah bootlegging I
don't give a [ __ ] just it's good to
watch it they're not sponsoring me
pirate that [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
don't do that I paid for it alright I
use expressvpn wings yeah exactly thank
you Dan the way to tie it in if you're
gonna pirate it use expressvpn cuz those
Disney guys are [ __ ] crazy man they
will come after you
the expressvpn comm /h 3 sonic made it
the new trailer so you guys remember
that Sonic the Hedgehog got a lot of
crap for the way that sanic looked and
they released the new trailer they
redesigned the body and I have to say I
mean here's the before and after of the
same shot that first one was so
remarkably as I'm looking just uncanny
freaky just so off I mean this is by the
way the new one actually looks great I'm
totally into it
but what do you see like their bodies
side by side that's when you really
couldn't he's like Slenderman body I
swear to God
like I would not this one everybody hang
on nobody panic
you look keep it together there keep it
together here this one to me showcases
look how freakish it looks like a dude
in a suit it looks like a dude in a
sonic suit no am I crazy it's still not
like the new one well it's more true to
the you know it's it's much better it is
better I don't know how anyone improved
the one on the left just looks awful
it's a dude in a sonic suit it looks
like some dude killed sonic took skinned
him alive well you know one or the other
right skinned him and put on his fur but
you don't like it well let's watch the
trailer you can see him side by side I
think we did get dinged when we watch
the original
because of the music and we don't need a
train
I was wondering for some way here you
can mute it I'm gonna open it
cuz I'm I know wonder if there's some
way we can like do cuz oh [ __ ]
like I don't know if they'll be able to
auto detect it if I if I recall the
original had that Coolio song in it the
Kings right yeah so this one has a song
in it as well so it's more about the
song than the trailer I'll watch it like
this I don't forgive [ __ ]
brilliant I'll do I'll do the mouse over
it and I'll go detecting big dicks not
gonna connect that how no sound effect
it aid sonic yeah [ __ ] okay
this is awful so that it starts with
Sonic doing a bunch of team sports by
himself I'm like this dude is lonely as
hell he's playing ping pong by himself
he was playing baseball by himself where
he hits it and then pitches it to
himself it goes to the outfield I mean
it's ultimately I I it's a kids movie
you know so but you know it's the same
actor from West world so I thought it
was it was a funny joke to say that it's
a weird expansion upon the West world
world how do you rate that joke Gila
alright alright thank you
huh not a good rate that was some
serious [ __ ] but there you have it I
think it looks way better I like the way
it looks
yeah well it's subtle hate it I mean
it's Sonic I don't like this kind of
animation yeah I mean it only looks like
the character now whereas it didn't at
all just don't like this three the kind
of character I don't know what to call
it
yeah hate that uh it reminds me of the
the Pokemon movie that came out last
year that bugged you to know little
Pikachu right well there you have it
people of fans of Sonic well people are
very happy that they listened
better for sure and revised it so at
great cost I'm sure in pain this is done
to the studio I agree and like I mean I
was shocked man when I went on reddit
this morning I mean people are really
showing paramount love they it's got
seventy thousand points is on the front
page what a way to turn the bad news
into good news right I mean they really
I guess I got a tip the beanie to them
for biting the bullet there this movie
needs to do so [ __ ] well for it to
not be underwater they're like canteen
they spend so much money I don't see it
happening but maybe I had to redo the
entire movie think about that like the
visual effects everything I think that
it's going to I think it's gonna do very
well there's been so much press and now
people are all stoked that it looks good
like if you go to the YouTube video the
the like ratio is overwhelmingly
positive there's getting tons that just
came out this morning it's got five
million views I mean look at the like
ratio it's like fantastic so we'll see
if people but I want to bet that it's
not gonna do that good we should take
that I feel like that drama is now over
well remember we actually we all like
now no one actually cares about saying
right then we did take votes we made
predictions about we need to revise that
well what we had we had bet on what we
thought the Rotten Tomatoes were would
be no but it was before they announced
that they were gonna redo everything can
you bring those scores up and we can
remove I'll take it up I think I said it
was gonna go to zero no I think I said
like 15 or something like that yeah we
were all we were all shooting pretty low
I need to revise it I think is it gonna
do successfully at the box office that's
another question I think you might be
right cuz I'll tell you I have no
interest in watching this film exactly
but a lot of people seem to want to
watch it there's anyone they just really
want to watch it I think I think it was
all about the drama and now now it's
over I was never a saved a kid I didn't
really play the Sonic games all that
much so I don't
have that much attachment to it I think
Ian is a big sonic dude though you know
you're gonna watch this film no oh okay
are you Sonic no yes I would have gone
when it was really bad cuz I think
that'd be funny no I don't want to go
anymore
no one's gonna watch it Wow
Zach you're not gonna watch this are you
no I have no interest at all oh wow
that'll be crazy that's gonna be crazy I
think a lot of kids are gonna want jobs
are gonna wanna walk but the thing is
here's what I'm confused about and
correct me if I'm wrong well they get
their money back I don't know after
redoing everything well here's something
you can maybe guys can answer me when we
were kids Sonic was part of our lives is
nostalgic this is a kids movie
none of us won't watch it our kids these
days playing Sonic do they care about
Sonic
that's a good point I mean they're
supposed to be us there have still been
Sonic games coming out over the years
but I don't think they're very
knowledgeable right so when we were kids
it was Sonic versus Mario they were when
he was as big as Mario but yeah not so
much anymore here we go I like the
Hedgehog rotten tomato predictions
Ethan you said 12 you know you said 20
was it but did we do like what the fans
are gonna give it tomatoes I'm gonna
revise mine to 50 because they have like
fan rating and critic
this is critic yeah this was critic
rating I can yeah I think I'm gonna
revise it to 50% I keep mine at 20
because I think the critics will
appreciate that they went through the
effort honey that's very low that's like
remarkably low yeah I think yeah that's
a for showing appreciation yes it should
be lower than 20 but they're pretty wise
lower but now instead it's staying at 20
okay
I'm 50 you guys want to revise Ian you
are up 14
[Music]
I don't know bump it up to 36 there you
go
Zach you at 35 oh are you giving 55 55 I
was at the zero yes
am i I mean that trailer did look pretty
cringy I don't know I obviously it's not
gonna be it's gonna be I'm still gonna
go under 50 I'm gonna go 40 I think it's
gonna be it's gonna be bad yeah I think
it's still gonna be and the question is
box office is this gonna be like a mega
duty flop well again I don't think it's
gonna be a mega duty flop but
considering how much they have to spend
now exactly like the budget of the movie
has got to be insane so it's passing
again it has to be like a smash hit for
them to not lose money on it I'm pretty
sure so we'll see see what happens
unless it wasn't as expensive as you
think then according to this the budget
was only 90 million is that before or
after the redoing at all though let's
see hmm let's see here
hmm
and you got to consider - so it's it's
may have been 90 million image
originally then they've redone all of
the special effects but what they've
also had to do is have two marketing
campaigns because they had a whole roll
out for this movie already last year and
all the outcry happened and now they're
gonna be advertising this [ __ ] out of it
again here's the thing I really gotta
like quadruple that 90 million know even
though yeah because the marketing is
almost always the same as the budget of
the movie they would be marketing the
film regardless I mean it's not coming
out till 2020 I bet you they're gonna
end up spending like 400 350 million
total wrong I don't think so
I don't think so I think maybe it would
go like 30% what it was at most well
regardless 90 millions less than I ate
than I expected and I'll tell you what
it's fairly low I think this movie's
gonna make money maybe or maybe it's a
total flop I'm very curious to know I'm
watching I'm gonna be watching closely
February 14th 2020 find out in three
months or so hopefully they sponsor Alan
time stay romantic it did really wait
that's got
like small box office numbers where the
[ __ ] is gonna take their date to see
Sonic that's just so weird
either you want to go on Valentine's Day
we're on our date already let's get a
nice nice meal and see sanic interesting
well III don't know I'm on the fence
it's it's either it's not gonna be a
smash hit that's for sure it's either
gonna barely make a money or it's gonna
be a colossal flop so that'll be
fascinating here's a surprise for you
guys
everybody watch closely this is really a
vital information Jeffrey Epstein being
deposed could you please give us your
name Jeffrey Epstein is it true sir that
you have what's been described as an
egg-shaped penis these types of
questions are not only argumentative but
directly to the manager embarrassed mr.
Epstein if you continue with this type
of question I will adjourn the
deposition immediately sir according to
the police department's probable cause
affidavit one witness described your
penises oval-shaped and claimed when
arrested it was thick towards the bottom
yeah but was thin and small towards the
head portion and called it egg-shaped
those are not my words I apologize but
as mr. adjourned as mr. critten has
stated that this is it that's a hell of
a way to open it how about that about
that I thought that was fantastic
can we I mean I feel like that's like I
mean I know they're talking about his
penis but I feel like that's the
cleanest Epstein video we can watch you
know what I mean I just that's a hell of
a way to to pose someone I wonder what
he was looking for okay he's like yeah
my penis is
shape that's like well I mean obviously
because there's a it was a police report
yeah but but what is he trying to get at
he's just trying to confirm the police
report I mean yeah it's like you know if
they can accurately describe his penis
that means they saw it could I have
different tactics like they're trying to
annoy you on purpose
well did I guess it backfired by the way
he could be like well I you know you can
say whatever you want a deposition no I
wouldn't describe it as an egg I would
describe it as large and glorious under
oath yeah no you're not under oath no no
you sure you can lie in a deposition you
don't want to lie but if you then then
you were under your you know you'll look
bad when when it's reread to the court
but you're not under deposition you know
it depends if you're in a grand jury you
are under oath but I'd like a deposition
in a lawsuit you're not under oath if
their position is the taking of an oral
statement of a witness under oath before
trial thank you I think I didn't know I
didn't know I didn't know I didn't take
an oath when I was deposed oh well maybe
it's different was that a civil suit
yeah I wasn't a criminal so I guess
maybe it's different I just I just
pulled up the deaf mean I remember I
don't know I heard I've never been
deposed so you I guess you're no better
than me um whatever yeah I mean you can
you can I don't i think that the shape
of one's penis is up for interpretation
anyway I don't think an egg shape is all
that video pop up I don't think someone
sent it to me an email I was I I'm
telling you I remember asking the
attorneys so somebody asked you can't
lie that's the whole point that's why
they tried to get you there they asked
you one thing and then they'll come back
to it again well they just want to show
you as dishonest and then they can play
it for the court but if it's a civil
suit what are they going to arrest you
for for lying it's different in a
criminal
whatever I am bears he's got an
egg-shaped penis that's the point of the
video we want he was he was not willing
to confirm its thick at the base and it
could become short at the top like a
like a caution cone it's like a bad
dragon dildo a lot of people look that
up and watch the podcast people close to
me and they were expressing surprise to
me about the bad dragons I was taken
aback I don't think anyone but you knew
about it
come on everybody out there knows was
act knows what I'm talking about
even Zack did he what you know about the
bad dragons no I was the first time I
heard of it I only one I heard about the
Avatar shaped flesh light like the alien
but no dragon so weird I'll people are
into the Avatar thing I always thought
the avatar aliens looks so weird yeah
but to go back to the point it sounds
like no one else knew about it I don't
know what to say I've seen it all over
the Internet what does that wear on
reddit I mean and okay when I'm looking
at porn it pops up in my feet like all
the time it's recommended you see some
girl [ __ ] identical people I'm not
watching anything crazy I'm telling you
the truth it's just a girl no I thought
you know I'm I'm not I'm I'm just blown
away that there's a market for that I
mean and sometimes you just click it at
a sheer morbid curiosity and you see
you're like what is going on it's like
this huge alien tentacles and some of
them are enormous like I know that that
was scary I'm going back in right now
it's fascinating it's like there's
disgusting there's ones that are like
giant horse [ __ ] and they shoot a ton
of like they have it rigged so they
squirt a ton of like jizz out like
buckets of it everyone watching knows
talking about no no it's the way you're
talking about me everybody knows what
I'm talking about
Zack knows he's just embarrassed because
his girlfriend no I really have never
heard about this
I love the mystic the mystic we got this
like unicorn horn and it's like rainbow
I think that there's one there's one
that um there's one that you see a lot
that's like it's like the monster like
drop mother dragon one that's like I
mean it's like I don't know it's dan
sound too judgmental don't don't keep
shame people that want a [ __ ] dreck I
point out lesson there's one called The
Winston tongue this is just the grossest
can you say it's me on this Court it's
not gonna open on the don't show the
screen oh I can see it you yeah wait let
me open this so hope I want to know how
big is this I want to get us huge so let
me describe this tour yeah oh there's a
size selector this is taking a long time
to load extra large websites very busy
why do they cut a Winston's tongue ever
since the podcast because there's a
there's an overwatch character called
Winston this is what I'm assuming
Winston overwatch it's not loading I
don't know the comments to tell them
knew about this before yeah go ahead
I mean and be honest you guys don't
throw me under the bus make me look like
an idiot
just be honest you've heard a bad dragon
or be honest if you're done be honest
because you all do it their websites are
God yeah weird I don't know we cry yeah
we loaded right up for me they're not
used to having more than two people at a
time after your easy so we've got let's
see here a plane crash is added to the
list of gender-reveal catastrophes
no incident occurred when a pilot flew a
crop duster style plane at a low
altitude in order to drop 350 gallons of
pink water as part of a gender-reveal
celebration
immediately after dropping the water the
plane stalled and crashed sustaining
damage to its fuselage and right wing a
photo from the incident shows the
mangled plane upside down in a field I
guess the person survived because that's
good but actually I have bad news for
you because in October an Iowa woman was
killed at a gender-reveal party after a
family in inverted Lee created a pipe
bomb
authorities say last year in Arizona wow
I guess they they they always celebrate
the gender let's kill the mom or kill
the aunt let's fill your heart we didn't
like that that was a shitty on anyway
you won't miss her mommy what happened
to aunt auntie Roberta
oh well she died at your uh at your
gender-reveal party you're bombed Sam's
party October and Iowa woman was also
killed at a gender-reveal party and her
family in a row I read that last year no
an Arizona wildfire that burned 47
thousand acres of land was sparked by a
gender-reveal smoke bomb
what is this Popeyes I have more Popeyes
violence by the way some really good
stuff happen at Popeyes I was I was
unsure I see that the ones that you have
in there and Manson had one man was
stabbed to death over an argument that
Popeyes actually this is a great story I
mean I don't have any images so I'll
just read the story to you but it's
fantastic people are dying in Popeyes
mean this is a national crisis this is a
[ __ ] emergency listen to this man was
stabbed to death Monday at a Maryland
Popeyes CNN I'll read article Kevin 28
was stabbed outside the rest
this is actually great he was pronounced
dead at the hospital surveillance
footage showed several people were
waiting in line yeah well I'll tell you
know it's justice it is justice and you
guys are gonna feel you guys are gonna
get a sense when I'm talking about shows
people were waiting in line for the
chicken sandwiches when Davis entered
the store and methodically started
cutting in line
haven't you ever confront fantasize
about confronting one of these guys I
always do well a man confronted Davis
about his conduct and 15 seconds later
the two went out of the restaurant door
to settle the score Davis was stabbed
Jesus how does the conversation lead to
homicide in 15 seconds someone asked the
chief called the stabbing a pointless
crime well he cut in line to get a
chicken sandwich from the guy who he
said let's settle the score [ __ ] was
stabbed you him carved you up like a
piece of chicken how do you stop lying
to death over that he probably got an
unlucky stab you know what I mean
probably got him in a good spot tender
spot police are looking for the suspect
who fled with a girl so they were
probably just went to the next closest
Popeyes did they looked at the other
Popeyes in the area cuz if you wanna
kill over Popeyes you want Popeyes
you're going to the finesse Popeye yeah
I can't believe you bailed after that
in a statement Popeye said they were
saddened by the stabbing but they will
not ever stop selling their chicken
sandwiches and they are secretly stoked
about how dank their sickens chicken
sandwiches are we do not yet know
whether this was a result overspeed
dispute over one of our products oh it
was come on look at the room look at
them so there you go I mean the guy cut
in line and he got what was coming to
what's going on
parfaits there's another one I mean
there's a video that I think it's
probably too violent but I'll play the
volume for you so there's again a white
woman goes to Popeyes in the wrong
neighborhood hey listen the audio I'm
not going to show you guys this is too
violent
you got this white woman she's calling
them the n-word there's a bunch of black
people there not only black people as we
as we discussed last episode of people
[Music]
but mostly black people
she's seems to be the whole name I mean
she seems his only wife but she's old
too and sterile to asking her to leave
and she just being her I mean she's
really really being nasty calling them
to n-word not leaving they keep asking
her to leave this goes on and on and on
she's being a total [ __ ] I don't even
know what they're arguing about so then
we go outside now there's when it gets
good we have a separate shot from the
phone outside the Popeyes she's being
chased out now the lady's punching her
what happened in that Popeyes was she
called them then word but I wonder if
she did something violent too because
they weren't violent but now it cuts the
next scene and one of the girls is
punching this old lady and the other guy
just body slams her could you see that
Dan we didn't show it but you saw it
yeah I've seen this video I mean it's
insane she gets no you can't I just have
the video and I've seen it before not so
I mean he put on the screen for you
there to see if she hasn't seen it we
won't say I won't okay okay but anyway
yeah I mean this big guy just grabs this
old lady picks her up over his head and
body slabs are I mean probably may have
killed her yes she's all I don't know
why she didn't leave earlier though she
was really pushing them to the limit I'm
not justifying it but pop I just crazy
I'm not gonna I mean dude Popeyes is
crazy puppies just Fight Club crazy
what's going on there man make the
sandwich a little that's good I know
they gotta tone it down here's a dry
bond or something
as Popeyes this good I mean what is
happening what's the best sandwich when
we tried okay but is it worth getting
bodyslam though no is working stabbed to
death over so you have a should we talk
about the conversation that regarding
the Popeyes cuz I know you haven't made
an email for my phone oh yeah I got an
email from an African American who
wanted to comment on my on my a comment
that black people love Popeyes and I
didn't say that for the record Dan said
that Dan put that out there dan said
black people love Popeyes I did say that
I actually talked to this van cuz they
emailed me as well so here we go this
from an African American fan chiming in
they said in regards to black people of
Popeyes comment that Ethan and Dan made
well again that was Dan who made that
just for the record I personally want to
say that I abhor Popeyes I have memories
as a child my mom taking me pop by as
far too often I'd ask her just to let me
get a side of dirty rice what's dirty
rice I don't like the sound of that
but a response I have always hear that's
not enough you got to eat and I'd end up
with large hunks of fried poultry in
front of me alas all black people do not
think feel or taste in unanimity
unanimity is that yes Union unanimity
yes this was just my experience however
I do challenge you that all that you all
@hp maybe try to dismantle and rebuild
your views on black people and fried
chicken it's a stereotype rooted in a
slavery to try to make this brief slaves
were typically only allowed to raise
chickens as opposed to other farm
animals this mutually generally there it
was only protein that most of them had
experienced in cooking as you could only
cook one type of meat you'd make it as
good as possible frying chicken worked
out pretty well because it kept better
when spoil is quickly and they were able
to experiment more seasoning which added
the factor of batter even after slavery
was abolished recipes were
down and fried chicken continued to be a
stable of black families despite white
people also enjoying fried chicken nope
yeah people do white people do not like
fried [ __ ]
okay of course white people everybody
loves fried chicken it's delicious but
the South still being extremely racist
there was a lot of imagery depicting
black people eating chicken and
exaggerated ways this reinforces the
racial stereotype of black people being
dirty well they don't okay because it's
food you have to eat with your hands I
won't go on much longer but it's always
been weird to me that why people are
more than ready to consume their fair
share fried chicken of which recipes
have been honed through over the
centuries of oppression but are the
first to say black people love fried
chicken back in the day we had to love
it
I wish fried chicken was food that we
could all enjoy together free of racial
divide much love Papa bless keep it real
and keep it teddy fresh and by the way
Briella who thank you for writing us in
where's Brielle Brielle Brielle
pronounced briella because she's got a
he at the end Brielle just not okay
Brielle I'm not good with this stuff PS
I've been a I haven't been in Popeyes 13
years maybe it's better not well
apparently it is apparently dan you
erased the anecdote about her being
interested in you what did you do that
didn't seem relevant to the conversation
but she wrote it dan what are you doing
what do you mean it didn't seem relevant
to the conversation what kind of
insanity what is he doing how could you
do this we won't read it but I got a
city aside by information I get well
because it was about me I would say I'm
irrelevant at least live it and we won't
read it because it was about you you get
to censor it that's not how this works
she's saying by the way it wasn't like
she was exposing you she said if dance
the next Bachelor I want to apply
because I think because I find him
attractive but why would you erase that
I feel like that's a good detail why did
you erase that because I'm telling you
because it is not relevant to the
conversation about the chickens let us
so hold on hold on is it you didn't
erase it because it wasn't relevant to
the chicken that's the only reason you
erased it yeah I think that it's
flattering why would you want to erase
something that was flattering to you do
you often get people writing and saying
talk to them because that seems like
self-serving to put something like that
I'm the one I remembered that detail and
that's why I wanted to bring it up I
thought that was the best part of the
letter well also for me I want to hear
that kind of feedback because let's
feedback on the show someone actually is
interested in the continuation of the
bachelor yeah weird at three I see I see
Kim well I mean do you want me to yes I
want to I want the full letter okay and
how dare you censor the suppression all
the after we're talking about unity
white and black people eating fried
chicken together and you're censoring
her uh I want to say one block fans
Rodin come on let's see the comment I
put it in discord discord he said on a
total different no this is the redacted
version a total different note is Dan if
Dan is the star the next season of the
h3 bachelor despite his racial views on
people of color please consider me as
the first contestant because he is
honestly cute AF I really enjoy consumer
of his voice and his reasonable opinions
she also put her Instagram did you look
at it I did not
you are [ __ ] lying you come on the
girl write you and say she thinks you're
cute I know you have a girl then doesn't
happen to be singles no I know but even
still you want to know what she looks
like
no wait then
unless you want to tell us something
what I don't get messages from people
saying they like me oh yeah you do
from ooh and if you do you better not
look at them I don't all my my dams have
been closed for years I don't take take
on but I don't expect them to look at it
because he has a girlfriend but your
cure I looked at it I was curious what
she looked like
okay well that's kind of different
because what I expected or this I know
but it doesn't matter he should be
curious to how he sure does he's
especially can't even look you know the
words The Bachelor and start foaming are
you serious yes why would it it's like
he's a spectator too in a way
no so why can he I look but he can
because it's different she's not
interested in you but it still holds the
same interest to him at me no you know
what I'm saying no it doesn't mean he
want he's a he's unfaithful in any way
it just means he's curious what she
looks like the same way I am well do you
see what I'm saying I wasn't curious
that's the damn that I would have a
problem with it I'm gonna put down on a
lie-detector test
[Music]
well maybe you should go on a lady
detective test mmm I said I looked at it
with the bad dragon I have met I'll tell
you I have met in my whole career
never got one email from a fan saying
good everybody now that they don't wanna
mess with me oh I like this new
possessive either but I thought you
would agree why should then look at
someone if he's in a relationship is not
like wandering eye it is no I swear to
god it's not like that
it is what is it but you admit that I
can look at it out of curiosity I did
look at it but that's different but Dan
should all it can also be curious from
the same perspective you just curious
who's reading this letter no you know
I'm right
and I disagree you guys want to chime in
on this no I don't want to get between
not you you don't feel calm man you're
you're in the middle of this but did you
not look because you felt like you're
obligated to not look I mean somewhat
but also just you know I saw that part
of the letter and was like oh I'm
flattered or whatever and then I moved
on because I loved there you go of
course I would look in there and not
been Zack well I mean if you if you're
faithful to someone like if you're in a
committed relationship why windows up
you know
I'm it's not window shopping just it's
part of the story you want to know who's
writing the letter you're not gonna
you're not gonna seriously consider
being like hey I'm hey thanks for the
letter how you doing
you're know that's that's a whole other
level that's not just looking I mean you
have no intention of doing anything
other than just seeing who wrote this
letter and don't think you would look I
would look if there was an Instagram I
would look I did if they worry if this
was about you though I would look it was
about anyone I would look I would go
look if it was about anyone a wannabe
because you're like thinking from the
show perspective I don't know but I'll
definitely look you know I'm faithful
you know I would never do I know you are
but I'm learning new things I know
you're faithful but I still think I
can't even look at who wrote the letter
because what is the purpose you're gonna
check if she is attractive or not mm-hmm
and what if she is that's it but what
good is that gonna do to anyone if she
was if this was about you it doesn't do
any good you're just curious I think
that's wrong
oh come on I do well I never get letters
like that well I mean you wouldn't look
at their profile if it was just some
goofy dude right there's like I'm I am I
would okay yeah I'm I don't know sure no
I would I'm genuinely curious like if a
guy wrote a letter said hey I want to
[ __ ] Dan I would look at his profile oh
good what kind of dude is Dan pulling I
would I would I want to see who twos you
know I want to see who's what's dampen
some good dick or not you guys all think
I'm way off base here
does everyone disagree with me it's I
mean not as much as I'm not your wife so
you know it's a different coming from me
I mean I I guess if you were curious you
know I'm not gonna fault you for that
but I also don't think you should be so
shocked that I I mean I I just I read
this through this email once I even
responded to her there's much I love
about it to erase it Dan because I'm
trying to move the show look what's this
look what's happened now
that's not your that's not your decision
to move the show oh I just I I said that
I was Dan you against her further
dialogue knowing she was interested
about about the past I said that I said
that you're totally right the way that I
articulated that was really clumsy and
didn't have a lot of nuance and what I
really meant use so hold on hold on and
after she expressed I really like his
reasonable opinions and the timbre of
his voice and so Dan further the
conversation with her I didn't think
about I didn't think about responding
she said I respond but I respond I'm the
one who goes through these emails that
she's attracted to him and you know what
I said I said I'm very humbled but I'm
not interested in putting myself up
through the torture that iam went
through I'm happily in a relationship at
the moment
moment anyways but thank you hmm you
addressed it yeah
I don't believe Dan didn't look at it I
do I just really didn't even I didn't
expect this to become a 30-minute
segment on the podcast you know I had a
lot of emails to get through I was I was
cranking these out
you saw the bit last bachelor you
expected this to not have it hold on but
I'm just like I'm not going through the
torture wait hold on am I just crazy
here in sac youjizz anyone back me up
here that you can look at a curiosity
what does it mean anything I think it's
for the show just to be curious but yeah
let me put it this way first of all my
dams have been closed for years and I
have never looked through my open dams
but it but first of all even if you're
looking through your open dm's I think
that's a problem I've never done that
yeah there's a problem ok but if
somebody sends me looking through your
open D yeah well like unsolicited dams
you're like looking for you're looking
through them no that's funny I look
through mine I get a lot of tips for
people send videos and stuff for the
podcast right it's different for you
guys I guess so
for me it's just fans to million
followers so it's just fancy you you
expect to get weird stuff in the open
DMS you know what I mean so first of all
that's been closed for years okay illa
because obviously that that would be
weird now somebody sent an email first
of all I've never got email like this
somebody sent me an email said I find
you really attractive yeah nobody would
I'm married the whole context changes
and I don't get what's the point okay
well because if somebody sends me an
email saying hey I find you really
attractive
yeah the context is like oh I want I
want you to cheat on Ehlo with me yeah
so obviously that's not something I'm
receptive to and I wouldn't but if you
take the step of checking their
Instagram profile it is a problem
because you are opening you are taking a
step into
the bad direction versus not even going
there at all that's how I think about it
but I looked at because I an if she
first of all I've never done this for
the record
so but I think Dan looked at it and I
think I don't think he looked at it I
looked at it I'm fine I'm fine with it I
looked at it I don't feel guilty about
it so why did she look like
normal well I don't want to make she's
pretty I don't want to make her she was
pretty what can I say you shouldn't ask
she's pretty she's a nice girl you could
have married her dan would like why do
you expect to see that's the problem
I'm just curious who sent the letter
there's no wind engine there's no
intention of anything beyond that first
of all we're talking completely
hypothetically I've never done this I
don't get emails like this
if you got one tomorrow you would learn
I would probably look so but it's but
green cedar no both conversation people
don't send emails like that to me but if
somebody man I don't know if somebody
said hey Ethan you're really attractive
you're on the next season of Bachelor
what would the email be like go ahead
and read it to me what do you man if
somebody sent me a note said okay Ethan
you're really attractive I think that
you should call me and you should forget
about ela no that's not how people talk
well then then that's the intention
though like if somebody wrote me email
like that that would be the intention
behind it because it doesn't matter and
if they flatter you
but anyway I'm still curious yeah what
if this what if it what if the email was
just simply something like and you know
MPs by the way Ethan I know obviously
you and EULA are happily married but I
just wanted you to know that I find you
incredibly attractive and I just think
you're the hottest thing and then an
Instagram tag would you check that
probably happy about that but just at a
curiosity there's nothing beyond that do
I buy the leg something and by the way
this has never happened but and I have
never done that
like I've never done that okay I just
want you to know that that didn't ever
happen okay but considering this
conversation starting tomorrow
yeah if you get that email I will not
look at it okay yeah I will not look at
it hey I read you loud and clear
no okay why don't you think it's a
problem if I looked at guys if they sent
me that it's not your it's not like it's
not like that
you're just curious I'm not I I I'm just
curious who sent the letter but I think
I would never contact them I would never
ever even if it was like oh I don't know
I would never contact them no matter who
it was it's simple it's just the gosset
II and think of the curiosity is a
problem I deal you know I'm a hundred
percent faithful to you aligned you
we're having the hypothetical quote
debate so I'm talking about it as if you
know but that's not unfaithful good
looking at someone's Instagram I think
it's a problem if they express that
they're interested in you and then you
go and check their Instagram it's not
like a dating profile as Instagram it's
not far from in dating yeah that they're
interested in you that's how you're
gonna contact them
I'm Instagram okay not that you're not
that you're going to contact them I'm
just a stop alone of looking at their
profile I think is a problem well I
wouldn't do that I would never do that I
would never do that I would never look
well usually we agree on stuff I find it
interesting that we disagree on this
yeah I guess so I mean again I've never
done that so I'm just trying to be like
brutally honest with you because I
thought people would relate to that but
there's no way that would ever be
unfaithful to you and a trilling you
hear you guys were like if you were in
this position so you're dating
and someone expressed dating a girl
happily married for 10 years
well I'm talking about them okay they're
not married yet so if someone expresses
interest in the girl and then she goes
and checks their Instagram profile first
of all would you not around them first
of all it's not just I'm a public figure
okay
people don't expect me to respond to
them and I don't ever respond to be I'm
not talking about responding and and and
by the way the fact that we're happily
married for 10 years makes it that more
ridiculous of an a notion that that I'm
interested in anyone else that I could
be interested in anyone else what do you
mean because like we're we're we're like
a happily married we have a great
relationship I cherish you but I'm not
talking about I'm just talking about the
act itself that I think it's a problem
I've never done it and I would never do
it I've totally done a 180 degree that's
why it's sleazy it's gross and anyone
who does that shame on them and I'm
gonna do that you didn't yeah I'm
curious still I don't what's the
question was a big deal if it was the
opposite for you and the girl that
you're dating if she got a letter like
that and then would you expect her to
not go and check the Instagram oh oh
she's like got an admiration letter yeah
I mean if I'd probably make me a little
uncomfortable and insecure I mean it is
I do see what Ethan saying it's
different like I've been dating this
girl for a couple months you guys have
been married four years so it's like a
little bit different but I mean on the
flip side you know I'm really happy in
this relationship and so that would be a
big red flag I guess you could say so
yeah I mean you know just clicking a
link yeah in that context it's not a
just like it is different for Dan
but he's still he's dating I'm not
dating I'm not I'm not looking right I
see what you're talking about although
it sounds like you're
IVA feels differently and so you should
really well again I'm not again this is
just a philosophical debate yeah yeah
we're done race
I have never I this is something that
happens this is a philosophical debate
evil is gonna treat me like she was
gonna act like I cheated on her now for
the rest of the week yeah they'd do
anything
can you guys back me up Duncan en are so
quiet somebody back me up I don't agree
with the almonds oh my god Zak if my
girlfriend was doing that like I don't
know it'd be like it's not doing that
it's not every day you're getting all
these admirations and checking everybody
out but yeah you said it yourself the
girl sent Dan a letter and I looked at
her profile out of a geyser you said you
order stood that because I feel like
that is somewhat different as someone
looking from the side on a situation but
look can't Dan have that not curiosity
no it wasn't it was a directed at you
yeah it's different but but yeah but if
I'm curious so is he no you should
pinpoint what the goal is there's no
goal you just know something there
whether you're trying to get like a
confidence or something yeah probably
something like that you know you want to
you want to see come on you guys how is
this how am I the only one I'm getting
nervous you might hear edge what is
going on I'm in a fresh relationship
we've only been going out for a couple
months it's going really great I'm not
I'm not [ __ ] around I'm not trying to
risk anything you know oh my god is not
okay I'm out I'm out you say it's not
risking anything but you have your wife
sitting across from you telling you that
that would be upset yes there's a I
guess I'm wrong because I can look
because at a curiosity has nothing to do
with you you're looking at a story from
the side right no
but if all of us are curious to look
let's say we all got that email you're
the only one I would look first of all
but you're saying that you did so I said
okay I can understand maybe you're
looking but I don't think Dan should
look okay I think we're beating a dead
horse here I think you know not gonna
change your mind just the point is that
if you're looking there you're trying to
see if she's attractive or not yeah
and that alone is not okay with me
being in a relationship it's like you're
it's like what you're gonna compare your
gonna and if she's more attractive like
where is it going you know it's only
gonna be bad there's no one more
attractive that's just the hypothetical
no are you perfect I don't there's
nobody else in the world
an attractive girl is like opening a
picture of beetlejuice it's the same
[ __ ] compared to you it's fine could be
a do a Terry but always have the same
well the same way it doesn't need to go
there now
this is just a hypothetical yeah and I
arguing just once again I've never done
that
it's totally sleazy and I'll never do it
and I don't even get emails like that
you're the only one you're going to now
I'm not clicking anyone put them all
this time gonna block them all and I'll
show you Ely here I got an email I'm
gonna block him I am I'm only trying to
be honest because yeah I looked at this
email that Dan gun I was curious what
she looked like and I looked and I feel
like that curiosity doesn't stop when
someone writes me one which hasn't
happened like that curiosity applies
across the board to everybody here well
I think it seems I ever want to hear
this agrees I think so I'm surprised but
it does seem that way yes it seems that
way so there you have it
I guess I gotta look at I gotta change
my attitude here a little bit it's just
curiosity I just I don't get it no that
doesn't make sense
but I'm a good husband nobody it's a
chance and I'm a good faithful husband
I mean result serious okay I've never
cheated I've never even I've never even
you know what I mean but you don't even
have to worry about what what what is
the angle correct you're curious what
are you looking to find out you're okay
I'm looking to see how attractive their
what they okay yeah so yeah but so but
it doesn't there's nothing else it's
just curiosity the same care us today I
have when I looked at the girl Rodin
delight you see Daniel you won't try to
erase this [ __ ]
yeah I bet you're wishing I you're
regretting calling me out on erasing it
now no I don't mind I am I don't mind
this conversation but I am surprised
that it just at the time people recoil
from what I'm saying so badly
I thought her commentary about the
chicken thing was interesting and worth
including we mean Eva are can at least
agree on that Dan yeah tell you the
truth the reason that I have done that
traditionally and yes I'll admit to
having edited some of these letters in
the past is when it's a big wall of text
I feel like you'll just see it you'll be
like that's you it's the only thing you
took out is one small well here that's
juicy as hell it's actually not true I
actually did cut another paragraph it
was she was just she was just furthering
the point that you read out and it you
know might you want I'm trying to do a
little bit of editorial control to keep
the that one probably had oh well y-you
knew you could you could highlight what
you want us to read maybe maybe I'll do
that in the future if I if I drop in a
three page letter I just feel like
anything's gonna see that me like that's
that's too much I'm not reading that
there's a chance
[Laughter]
you don't have you don't have any
concern of me ever cheating on no I
don't so that's my point like how like
you're not you're not worried we're in
this happy healthy beautiful marriage we
cherish each other
I still have their act first of all
again I want to emphasize this isn't
something I've ever done okay good yeah
but we're talking about if you were to
do it hypothetically then I never would
say I'm not gonna get in trouble for a
hypothetical at least do it [ __ ] do
anything I'm getting [ __ ] yeah hey Ethan
what do you think of the hashtag maggot
challenge I can move it along
yeah but we're we're a team are we ready
to move along yeah I think so okay thank
you are you angry at me no okay
it seemed like you were getting upset at
certain times during that conversation
well you know I mean today is really
temperent no it's fine I
I don't mind you getting fired up I just
don't want to be like actually offending
him about what I'm saying you know I
don't want you to I don't want to make
you feel bad
anything I'm sure I'm just I'm no I
don't feel bad not joking you know that
I cherish you among all every everyone I
in my whole life you are the you are
everything to me I believe you and I
believe then that it didn't look at the
link well I think Dan's lying that being
said let's move on to the maggot
challenge I'm curious what the people
think about this conversation yeah and
I'm very curious you know I I felt like
I was just being real I was cutting
through the [ __ ] I mean I've no
doubt that you're being real it just
just kind of back my butt and Dan's wine
come on Dan's not being real all right
that's good you guys heard about the
maggot challenge that shit's cringy as
hell no matter what you think about
Donald Trump love
hey limp or think he's okay we can all
agree that this is awful
Donald Trump retweeted this guy so by
the way you did um you uploaded these to
see if they got claimed right I did and
I even found the original rap that
they're all rapping over and uploaded
just that and no claims nothing drastic
so uh uh this guy first of all made this
rap let me start here
he says mega boy mega challenge I want
you all to make your own rap to it and
then tag me
let's make liberals cry that seems to be
the central theme of the raps is making
liberals cry and I don't quite sure what
that means but Donald Trump retweeted he
said I will announce the winners of the
mega challenge and invite them to the
White House to meet me and perform I'd
really doubt that that's never gonna
happen meet me and perform wait do you
see this [ __ ] I think Trump was
expecting like Kanye to submit or
something but this is original libs are
crying right now
I am NOT a big dumb I am not oppressed
they keep taking shots on my spot back
and said I went my Mac I had some say
[Music]
okay I kind of like his I like his style
I like his there I'm honest and I'm
gonna hate that Big Mac I had his dope
but so that that one's actually not that
cringey I like you know this the cringe
follows what next so here I mean this
this one is is I think the cringy [ __ ]
ever
well they got worth in my opinion but
like imagine from this guy this is
probably the biggest response imagine
Trump inviting this guy to perform this
30-minute song it's crazy
[Music]
correct me if I'm wrong but this guy's
white right yeah yeah isn't that like
what black people say about like black
people are supposed to vote Democrat I
don't think what was an assumption about
white people
I keep watching cuz I'm I mean you he
calls me yeah what the [ __ ] they could
be the saturation yeah everything maybe
he is just reiterate I think this is the
same lyrics as the first guy no just
somebody else's song oh well then I
don't know what the [ __ ] no yeah you
didn't say that is because I don't start
yeah we can compare notes he definitely
didn't say that oh damn it this Twitter
yeah this guy didn't say that
[Applause]
all right he said white liberals times
Helmut Lang on which makes more sense
than this white guy saying it he's white
right and also he did his own back
backup vocals I love that way I mean the
only thing I can think of is that it's
super expiry remember ATS let's see
let's go find out we're out if this
guy's black or white Ram rants maybe you
shouldn't do this son we have another
screencast in case yeah oh maybe you
should look it up there yeah I can
logged in yeah you guys can tell us oh
maybe this is him you care this is the
original post oh he is black Oh crazy
yeah thing is just a crazy lasting white
boys [ __ ] okay I was like what I didn't
suspect he was black at all but there
you have it the power of saturation yeah
exposure well that made a way more
cringy that I thought he was what's
still bad bad go Trump go Trump if you
let your money go Trump and 2020 go
Trump if you like your money and then he
gives us like a seductive wink at the
end can you imagine doing it he's gonna
go put on that for Trump at the White
House give him a little wink at the end
the classic believe this guy can't he
can't not snack during the show I have
to ban
eating on the show no well it's been
kind of a mean no dammit I can't handle
more than one person smacking
I asked in calor I loved women now you
can yeah I mean I don't want to hear it
I don't think the audience wants to hear
you eating for sure
well at least I'm the host I mean it I
just chewing off-screen it's kind of
weird you know anything okay now this
one's fire I don't care what you say
about the other one this one's making me
vote Trump heard of performance at the
White House
you gotta pull that sound bite
[Music]
who comes inviting her to the White
House to perform that oh so you know
he's not choosing a winner
why didn't just pick the guy who
actually is good and made the challenge
you know um I just want to say that we
do need to and pretty what I'm just
getting this started
you look that's what this began how long
has it been about two hours just enjoy
that let's get through the maggot
challenge I have to talk about chaos I'm
local pulled two baggage on
[Music]
[Music]
going to the White House Hey
go Maggie kid give it up to God
Oh oh yeah he's going to the way he is
going to the mother-effing white this
one this did you upload this one cuz
cheese is a different beat I did I it
also did not because this one's pretty
yeah she does in the car by the way how
much I don't know where they make I'm
sure you do that you know that they make
those megawhatts and sharing I think
they got hold out for that so hard that
they started making them super cheap I
need her I need all these people to
perform
uh-oh way what's driving her right now
the someone in the car well I know a lie
when I smell it
Wow I just looked it up they're actually
made in Long Beach the maggots yeah
right here right here and God bless it
uh California Wow baby alright let's
let's wrap it up then Logan Paul verse
ksi I watched this fight it was on ozone
which was a paid app it cost 20 bucks to
purchase the fight to watch it on this
app excuse me
logo Paul first ksi was this weekend
held at the Staples Center where the
Lakers play pretty big stadium it looked
full to me when they were there but I
don't know they can move people down I
don't know whose people them but it
looked it looked back case I came out
the winner in the end by split decision
and their sixth round cruiserweight bout
that was helped by Jeff by referee Jack
Reese he gave a controversial two-point
deduction on Paul for holding and
hitting ksi when he was down around four
now I saw that as a pretty dirty mm-hmm
can I show the clip do you think am I
gonna claim to ass probably claims I
mean what if I make it strong they have
anyway yeah they did little still claim
us anyway yeah there was a moment where
so Logan landed this I mean it was the
best punch of the of the match for sure
this absolute brutal uppercut on ksi and
I actually gave ksi a lot of credit for
soldiering through that because he got
career
it was a massive uppercut but the thing
is ksi was falling and Logan was hitting
first of all looking threw him to the
ground and then he punched him when he
was on the ground yeah and the ref was
like what the [ __ ] are you doing and he
deducted two points for for that
flagrant I mean I mean it was it was
just so unsportsmanlike and Logan even
says at the end he's like my emotions
got the best of me it's like so you
punched a dude on the ground at anger
what is that mm-hmm and now he's
bitching about the two points that got
deducted because he says he would have
won yeah I felt like when we both
watched it so I felt like there I don't
know anything about the sport okay so
fine take that into consideration but
from my perspective I felt like it was
closed but I was rooting for ki cuz he
was giving it more like he was yeah more
he wanted it more he was taking it
serious at like 1,000% which was cool to
see well they were showing the backstage
footage and Logan Paul's like pre-fight
interview was he was just being goofy
and clownish and like doing his shtick
and I was turned off by that it just
seemed like he wasn't he wasn't his
heart and soul into it where ksi was
like in the zone he was all about it and
I could just tell that the heat there
was more fight and ksi and I mean he
really dude he got hit so hard you guys
I mean he really yeah it took a lot to
to recoup from that and there was a
there was a moment I thought he was
gonna lose because he was he was really
um he was really shaken by that punch
and they were zoom boxing and as the
judge said that Logan he lacked the
instinct to know he should have gone
after him but I feel like Logan he just
he's but he never really Unleashed
Darren go for it boxing his heart out i
always wondering the whole time if she
was saving something for the end right
but he was I never did yeah I mean even
when ksi was like seriously and wounded
he lacked the instinct to go get him
he could have ended the fight right
there forget about the score being minus
two points I mean he blew it right then
and there and ksi recovered after that
and I think ksi won he just you know he
fought more aggressively he got more
points he landed more punches and I want
to give him more points on that outfit I
liked it better than Logan's there you
have it you look like a Mortal Kombat
but actually Logan I have to say I do I
have to criticize Logan a little bit
with how he handled the loss because
first of all he says I let my emotions
get the best of me but I will say I got
no warning and I got two points taken
away from me yeah you punch someone when
they're on the ground that doesn't
happen that's why I lost tonight do the
math I would like to contest this
commission because I did not receive a
warning I don't think that's fair at all
that's what he said on the post
interview on the stage so he's already
talking about how he wants to contest
the loss and then later on he says he
says that he was sick which he never
mentioned anywhere here this is from BBC
he says that he was uh this is such
[ __ ] this is later on after he lost
he's getting interviewed by some media
and he says I woke up sick it took
thirty to fifty percent out of me like
he didn't mention that anywhere else he
was totally fine the whole time he even
said in his pre-fight interview I feel
great I feel great he said then all the
sudden when he loses I gotta check with
the Commission and I was sick it took
3050 percent out of me he says I beat
ksi 11 out of 12 times but I want to say
in general that I was totally ready to
watch like a crane fest and I didn't
feel like that at all actually I found a
good match I found the whole thing very
entertaining I was glued to my set and
it was kind of cool to see the just like
the whole setting is so professional
like so like you would watch the actual
game but then with these familiar faces
from YouTube because he gets kind of
funny yeah I totally agree I mean
it was it was professional through and
through another thing that shocked me
was Justin Bieber and Logan Paul's
Locker before the game leading them in
prayer expected he's like damn sure I
got an image of it here here's Justin
Bieber leading Logan Paulin they don't
work by the way God did not answer their
their call God was like maybe you should
have just trained harder I don't know
but Logan lost and I have to say I mean
I think everyone was happy about that I
hate to say it
Logan was getting booed in Los Angeles
and he started when he started making
excuses on the stage people started
booing him because they had a really
good sportsmanship moment where they
hugged and said right next each other
and then Logan started going on how he's
gonna contest this decision and everyone
started building it it's over well and
then there's this great moment where he
goes they go Logan would you refight ksi
I'm not showing I look at any of the
clips because I'm gonna get claimed but
they say Logan would you get would you
do another rematch with ksi and he goes
yeah I do that and then they go ksi
would you refight Logan he's like hell
no I'm done I won this is over and I'm
told I totally get that I was yeah I'm
out you got to see Jakes outfit where's
that one right here Jake was there and
dude man you guys got to see this outfit
this was the worst thing ever
this guy is the corniest [ __ ]
alive he's got a cane first of all and
talk about what are those I mean what
are those what are those whose time is
that like what is this it's like it's
like the visor is so [ __ ] funny some
it's like a there's a matrix joke there
right it's kind of like a grandma matrix
it's like a tunic and it tights a deep v
I mean yeah tights to go like just below
the knee no socks a
Payne he's like Elton John and the
matrix he does have an open John vibe I
don't know why he's got this huge visors
on like he just got cataract surgery
yeah that's the grandma part I mean this
is just I mean is this high fashion HeLa
what do you say your fashion your your
cart or court or a court or or sure how
do you say it Couture Couture your court
or is this coat your glasses the visors
what do you pray appreciate the effort I
guess I don't like necklace I like the
necklace but not with this outfit do you
think he had a stylist or do you think
he dressed himself question you like the
cross and maybe 10 ah interesting
oh yeah that makes sense that the part
that hurts me is I know this is all
really expensive designer [ __ ] and he
still looks like a clown yeah I mean I'm
sure that how do you feel about the
deep-v I don't like it I'm not into that
what about the cane and war more than
anything here I hate the length of those
pants the pants were just a nightmare
and then there's no socks where are
those shoes I mean really what are those
I'm sorry Jake take it from me someone
who really knows about fashion that's
officially bad out of it what Dan what
are you pooping about no I'm a fashion
icon that's that's very true I kind of
like his shoes if I'm being honest I
mean the rest the outfit is clownish but
I mean I don't know they look clownish
in context to the outfit I guess Dan
likes your shoes Jake
I mean his can sit up to and his visor
and I like his shirt no I think the
shirts the work yeah the shirt in fact I
wouldn't because like the pants are
super tighten the shirt is like super
long it's just I don't know man that's
been a look lately though hasn't it been
you would know better that's not a life
right no like the oversized hell off but
the not my kind of look but it's a look
for sure so he is sufficient
it's more like Jersey Shore's fashion
it's like high-level Guido [ __ ] you know
what I mean yes it's like trashy fashion
yeah
tasteless fashion that's fine I I
honestly don't really like bashing
people so much for their taste I mean
mm-hmm
that's just it's it's so subjective it's
just not bad no I mean I already said I
didn't like yet there you go thank you
I'm at any rate I have to say overall I
enjoyed the fight I was entertained I
was very impressed both the guys were in
top physical shape they both obviously
trained really hard case I put up a
really good show he fought his heart out
Logan I'm just I am disappointed me he
landed that one monster uppercut that
really almost ended the fight but I just
feel like he didn't attack enough and
ultimately case I just won by sheer
determination yeah but I
but you guys saw the fight what did you
think yeah I mean Logan 100% blew it
yeah he totally blew because it wasn't
just about the deducted points it was
because of those because of the foul
because he punched him in the back of
the head and when he was on the ground
they gave kiss I I think he was allowed
to have up to five minutes to recover
yeah he had a lot of time to recover
after that monster hit he was able to
take as much time as he needed to if
that hadn't had like even if he had
slipped that you know it was oh right
back into it yeah I mean fight at door I
think I Fred is about to [ __ ] in our
office who take care of him in a second
but yeah he blew it like he he would
have cured him that round
um yeah dude he could have just blown on
him and never fallen over but I mean
again you don't like dude talk about
blown I mean you not you got this
monster punch and you had to hit him
when he was on the ground I mean dude
that's like solo life I know
exactly but in his defense he didn't hit
him really hard no it's the moment and
he's not a professional yeah
you know I don't know unless you have
your own shop you know exactly we've got
a lot of content left but I think we
better wrap it up because I'll fred is
about to poop on the carpet
congratulations to ksi gratulations to
both of them it was very entertaining I
can't even really hate on it now I don't
actually I thought it was great
yeah keep an eye on out Fred someone
pick him up so he doesn't go yeah yeah I
can't hate congratulations to them both
and Jake's outfit was awful though right
we agree on that
can we hate on that no there's no hating
happening on it we got a eight on
something we're hating on me today for
being disloyal to the perfect the
perfect woman in yellow I've only ever
been faithful for ten years of marriage
well that wasn't the conversation I've
only been I've only tried every day to
be the best husband I can be but no I'm
unfaithful because I looked at someone
that wrote Danny email that is not the
conversation okay can you put on the
music while we wrap it up enjoy this how
many times have we seen a mobility
person gonna hit a skate park it just
doesn't work you know the problem is is
that people really underestimate like
that's not a steep hill and these things
cannot go uphill man they just really
can yeah it's just like see no scooters
here and then this dude just hit me no
fat
razor flip unrelated content there's a
music on yes sir good well today's
Tuesday Friday we've got Whitney
Cummings actually you should put up a
question thread I show Whitney Cummings
we're excited for that strangely only
our second female guest ever is I write
no second solo yeah that's so weird
we've had Christina and Jenna
oh yeah I never they were both with
their significant others oh my god right
so it's a first solo female guest no no
don't know if that counts if she's the
trans male she's a man right so check
out that uh that threat that'll be up by
the time the episode goes up well I'm
very excited to have her and I look
forward to that one Friday and I hope
for you guys to join us then and until
then it'll be a fantastic week a great
time and uh remember don't go don't go
opening those Instagram your whatever
you do right Dan right right alrighty
guys we'll see you then have a great
week top table we love you appreciated
the watching I appreciate it gotta go to
get away together but yeah Alfredo's
waving goodbye